but when they become
hysterical about somebody and they're
like he's a conspiracy theorist without
even refuting what he told you then you
know he's on to something I mean a hurt
dog barks right when you have an
infection someone touches near the
infection it hurts what does that tell
you you have an infection yeah oh I see
what you're saying well do you think
that's one of the reasons why Bobby
kenned was looked at as so crazy 100%
yeah and what's so funny is I said I saw
him uh you know very recently the other
night and I said to him and I saw him I
sort of follow it I'm just interested in
the reaction to Bobby Kennedy and
remember they attacked him as a crazy
conspiracy nut because the vaccines and
he said there may be a connection
between the vaccines and autism like
shut up and they literally they canceled
his contract with the New York Times he
had a contract to write for them they
canceled it wow and they just basically
drummed him out of plate Society they
don't talk too much about that anymore
right but the vaccine stuff because I
think there is this recognition and by
the way I'm not an expert but that
actually a lot of people were hurt a lot
of people were hurt not just with the
most recent round of mandatory vacs but
in earlier rounds now you could argue it
was worth it you we have a flu vaccine
it academically supposedly prevents the
flu so maybe we get it and but some
people get hurt but they were telling us
for years nobody gets hurt well that's
just a lie does does Bobby Kennedy Jr
have any chance does a third party have
any chance these days no a third a third
party can affect the outcome for sure
but the system is I mean this could
change with time but the system it's
it's so it's shown sign of changing I
could bore you for hours but you know
Ross Pro ran in ' 92 and then '96
remember you know and he got Clinton
elected the ears that was the campaign
thing fear the years I never heard that
I remember made it up that was good
thanks but he and he actually was was
kind of impressive in he was a real
smart guy huh he was he was and he said
a lot of things that turned out to be
true but of course he was attacked as
some kind of crazy person but um
including by me I should say damn really
yeah I was used as a tool the point
point is he got 23% or whatever I think
it was 23 that year in Lo pero did oh
yeah wow oh dude cuz he was running
basically on pre you sort of a pre-trump
more restrained more academic you know
less you know less Trump but but the
idea was the same like manufacturing is
dying and it's going to wreck the
country we need to make things stuff
like that bush perau and dakus no who
was that no dakus was 88 it was Bush
perau and Bill Clinton wow who was then
the governor of Arkansas 1992 was the
first race I covered and perau did
really well despite massive hostility
from the media because of course they
were
protecting yeah you know their bosses
estment exactly that's exactly but I
didn't perceive any of 18.9% he got what
did he get 18.9 19 I'm sorry 19% I'm
embarrassed did he affect the outcome of
that race oh well he he won it for
Clinton I mean Clinton won it as you see
on the page at 43 43% absolutely if Pro
didn't win do you think that bush wins
that of course yeah oh absolutely he
took from Bush yeah who is Kennedy
taking from what do you think Trump you
think of course there's no person who's
thinking H I'm gonna vote either for Joe
Biden or Bobby Kennedy I have some
friends that are no way I swear really I
have some friends that are that have
known Bobby I mean these are people that
have known Bobby Kennedy for a long time
and but who are Democrats who are like
this is my guy the only reason you would
vote for Joe Biden is cuz you believe
there safety and numbers you're voting
for the party you're not obviously I'm
not attacking Biden but you're not
voting for Biden you're voting for the
Democratic party because you think when
they have more power you're safer or
richer or whatever that's the only
reason and Bobby Kennedy man I mean I've
never seen anybody get right to the core
issues affecting the country the way he
has and I don't agree with him on
everything but I mean he names names I
mean in a big way yeah that's why I love
him I think well I just think he can
[__] he doesn't know I I don't feel like
he's in anybody's pocket do you feel
like lowkey there's some party that's
like planted him in there people say
that but that's that's crazy [__] I
think um I I mean I feel like I know
Bobby very well and I I am totally
convinced just on a human level that he
is an honest person too and I don't
think that he would do that and um I
just have to ask are there people in his
orbit who would do that I believe yes is
the answer but I don't think he knows
has anything to do with it I think he's
totally sincere he's certainly not in
anyone's pocket I mean the guy could be
his name is Bobby Kennedy he's the son
of oh we could do whatever he could he
could do whatever he could do whatever
and and he has done he's done a ton of
great stuff with his life he has but I'm
just saying it's very easy to be loved
by everybody and to just it's very easy
to make money when everyone loves you
Bobby Kennedy could have an infinitely
easier life than the one he's chosen
he's doing this because he sincerely
believes it look at that right and he's
under threat I mean I was with him on
the street the other day this week in
Washington and the security people
around him were very nervous oh he was
not nervous at all but they were anyway
the point is I think Bobby's totally
sincere but he is giving a massive
middle finger to The Establishment like
almost as aggressively as I've ever seen
anybody why can't we get him to a level
because what percent does he have to get
oh I guess I don't we don't know because
you don't know need to get that
plurality you know we'd need to get more
than the other two and unfortunately the
system is set up where it's hard for a
third party guy to get on all the
ballots I mean they've rigged the system
against a third party challenge because
they don't want that who has rigged the
system both of the parties both both of
the parties yeah of course of course
they don't I mean once you have power
what's your number one goal it's
preserving it and preventing people from
challenging you you know of
course